[Music]
I'm realizing more and more about why I
am the way I am from when I was really
little and I could hear my mom and dad
arguing like about money or something
I can't talk to them about that because
all they want to talk about is how
tender the chicken is that's the idea of
a deep chat you know every single time
we're eating someone who variably comes
out of a comment about the tenderness of
the meat
mom was depressed and I never really
focused on that but it's clear that she
was and I think that man if I had a
problem that it was always a problem too
much I know it dad were arguing all the
time which obviously doesn't help things
I think that's why I have these issues
with confidence and this whole like
background of shame all the time and
probably why I do this OCD type stuff
and explains drinking and explains drugs
like
[Music]
huh he's very tender extremely tender
we're not talking about something other
than the food good come here every
Sunday and we eat and all we talk about
is the food
I've been reading this a lot and I think
it explains a lot about why things keep
going wrong why I can't start a new
relationship why works all over the
place it's because I haven't received
that bedrock of human love that everyone
needs I only want four more vegetables
this is why I think me and I was broke
up in the end Ernest what are you
bringing her in for good open I bought
the one if you prefer forgive I just had
that confidence confidence what's that
got to do with anything would you like
some more ice cream it's tired to see a
therapist why not a magician next gone
mum it's not the Middle Ages it's a
normal thing to do it's just good to
have someone to actually talk to about
how are you feeling you charge him I'm
um been fishing anymore this month Ian
no I don't mean that hmm your Aunt Sarah
was here the other night her relatives
just got into University I'm not saying
these things to be mean
well maybe you should think about it
before opening your mouth I just think
it's good to have a song like
constructive non blaming conversation
about the way you feeling
to fit up with the tell ya
[Music]
now went to fetch tables in here yeah
ma'am
make sure you leave them you'll get a
bit slim I want it getting enough yes
yes
[Music]
and then yeah yeah it was okay sort of
yeah we talked what we just doing really
talked about that kind of stuff like I
just feel I was probably not
conversation I'm gonna have him my
parents yeah probably better if it's
just me and you and therapists and you
know that mm-hmm did get some pretty
good chicken though very tender the dark
truths in our book things you should
never tell children may not be suitable
for children but the book can offer
solace humor and relief to the older
ones among us click the link to learn
more